[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello
i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at long now
i'm joining you from the interval here
in san francisco where i'll be joined
by adam rogers our speaker tonight who
is going to be speaking about the
history
and future of color and perception and
culture
adam rogers was one of the very first
speakers we had here at the interval uh
way back in 2014
on his last book proof which was really
a kind of a similar study
but on alcohol and culture but tonight
he's going to be talking about
both the science and history of color
and perception and how it has affected
civilization through time
welcome adam rogers thank you xander
it's really it's good to be back
uh i want you to picture in your mind
the quintessential yellow so not an
object
not a yellow thing not a lemon
but just yellow not orangey not greenish
yellow okay you got it
now i don't know if this is it for you
this is how a lot of computers code
like yellow yellow and of course it'll
look different on every screen because
nobody calibrates the colors of their
screens and all screens are different
all things being equal though and this
is a little bit weird
the yellow that you would pick as
perfect as quintessential if somebody
shined a light and gave you the controls
of the dials to pick a perfect yellow is
probably very very close
to what another person would pick of
course all things are never equal we
measure color in a lot of ways
saturation brightness intensity
and those metrics vary from place to
place in time to time when we talk about
color let's try another warm up now i
want you to picture your perfect green
so not bluish not yellowish green
okay you got it now here's a weird thing
the green in your head right now is
almost certainly
not the green that someone else would
think of or would pick as their
quintessential green
people vary by a lot if you shine do
that thing where you shine the light in
their face and let them control the
dials it'll vary by as much as 60
nanometers if
describing colors by their wavelength is
your thing
this is a good green it's fine um
it's a little yellow for me actually but
an important question asked here i think
is
why would this green not be your perfect
quintessential green
because the blue-green region of what
scientists call a color space
the entire multi-dimensional range of
colors
and variations in colors possible and
perceivable is a brutal
place it is a weirdish wild space now
partially
this is because of how your eyes and
brains work partially it's a function of
your personal experience of philosophy
of language of all the green lights
you've ever seen every traffic signal
every green field of england every
blade of grass every incredible hulk
color is physics color is culture and
you probably remember something
from elementary school called primary
colors the idea of those is that you
could have specific colors or
really and we'll talk more about this
too specific names
for colors that we agree upon and then
somehow try to understand
how those colors mix and come together
to form all the other colors because of
course color
is a continuous sort of curve or wave
form i guess
there's red yellow blue those are the
primary colors i was taught there's red
green blue those are the primary colors
your computer was taught
there's the muncell primary colors which
is a system of organizing color
this sort of unifies them all for
comparison's sake you can see how
different they are around the outside
is what isaac newton called the spectrum
the middle ring are the
artists primaries and secondaries and
the inner ring are the additive colors
red green blue shine light put those
together they mix and form other colors
and the subtractive or reflective colors
that you'd find in a pigment cyan
magenta yellow and
black cmyk history is littered
with the rubble of attempts to put
colors into some kind of order
to make them behave so that printers and
painters
and dyers weavers and digital animators
and
artists of all sorts and people every
day can use them
can take this mysterious but ubiquitous
feature of the universe
and turn it into something that we
change that we transform that transforms
us
into a technology so here's the
hypothesis
when we talk about color we are actually
talking about three separate but related
and overlapping things
so first is color that happens without
us the tree falls in the forest it's
green even if we're not there
to see it tumble that's physics
chemistry the oscillation of
electromagnetic fields moving in a
direction
electromagnetic energy streaming from
the sun hitting earth's atmosphere
interacting hitting other surfaces and
particles
light 1.21 sextillion photons
hitting every square meter of earth's
sunlit surface every second
color is something that we make colored
things by dint of our hands and our
effort and our cognitive abilities
roman purple egyptian blue move colors
that didn't
exist on earth or anywhere in the
universe i mean you know maybe
until human ingenuity makes use of all
that physics and chemistry to make them
happen
usually we call these things pigments
these are things that absorb some colors
of light and reflect others presenting a
color to our eyes
the image that you see there are jugs
full of quantum dots eventually those
are going to be part of led tvs
it's arguably one of the most advanced
way people make colors today
and third there's the color that our
eyes and brains manufacture from those
other two things
light all around us bounces off or
through or among
surfaces into our eyeballs where
hideously complicated biological sensors
transduce
photons into neuroelectrical signals the
image that you see now is uh
ramona kahal's hand-drawn map of a
mammal's retina
that comb-looking part up at the top are
the rods and cones
those are the photoreceptors the back of
the retina that
perceive light and color this is isaac
newton's original
spectrum um with colors added later he
didn't draw the colors in when he did it
famously in 1665 he goes on the run from
the plague and hides out at his mother's
house
closes up the shutters with the study
he's working in pokes a hole in the wall
sunlight comes in he
lets that sunlight go through a then
relatively new optical technology called
the prism
and sees on the opposite wall color is
splayed out in a line
the eyes in the brain don't perceive the
same world of color that the universe
creates
what we think of as color is like all
the other senses
just an approximation so that first way
of looking at things this is
going to be familiar to you this is the
electromagnetic spectrum colored light
is in one sense just the teensiest part
of the
physics that surround them and this sort
of makes sense why it's that narrow band
because we're using meat sensors to
perceive it longer wavelengths
uh would cook those meat sensors and
shorter wavelengths would ionize them
into little balls of cancer
we humans call anything between about
380 nanometers and about 750 nanometers
we call that stretch visible light those
are colors
to us you can see here that the peak
spectra of the three of them that most
human beings have in their eyes
people call those red green and blue or
short medium and long wavelengths but
you can see that the peaks aren't well
distributed
the tails overlap this is like
everything else
in our meat suits an evolutionary cluj
and in some humans
one or two of them doesn't work
somewhere humans have a whole
other one of them in there in between
the green and the blue
they are tetrachromats as opposed to
most of us
trichromats um but the wavelengths it
responds to still fall inside the range
of what we
tend to call visible but look at this
birds are tetrachromats they see colors
way down into the ultraviolet
and bees they're trichromatic like us
but they don't even bother with red
they're seeing the green and the blue
and then ultraviolet the natural world
positively glows to these other animals
we can't even begin to imagine and we
can begin to imagine but we don't see
what they see they have other
colors and look at this show off this is
a mana shrimp 12 photoreceptors
into the uv and near infrared jerks i
mean now except for the colors out on
the edges
uh most scientists don't actually think
that the manta shrimp sees
more colors than humans it might not
discriminate among a zillion where we
only do a kajillion or something like
that
it does do it faster the connections
between those receptors and what
what passes for a brain and a mantis
shrimp i'm not trying to be offensive
but you know
man to shrimp but the point that i'm
trying to make here is that color
is quite literally in the eye of the
beholder
what colors we see depend on our our
biology the cones sensitive to long
middle and short wavelengths i'll do
something called quantum catch they're
kind of adding up the number of photons
they're receiving at the energy levels
that they're sensitive to
this is a function of the proton
structures around them responding to
that energy
they aren't just sending red green and
blue signals back into the brain they're
combining their signals with each other
and with other kinds of neural
other kinds of neurons adjacent to them
and other kinds of cells that are
helping that process doing
complicated calculations within the eye
they're also doing overall number of
photons to calculate
brightness or intensity because the
amount of light and dark is part of the
way we perceive color
and then that all reaches back you can
see in this diagram those two circles at
the top there are eyeballs everything
else is brain
and once you get into the brain what you
would love to say is like oh well
there's like a part for red and a part
for blue and a part for
green but no it's not like that at all
the parts of the visual cortex may or
may not map to specific colors
perceptions of colors
the neuroscience community has been
arguing about this for decades we
don't even really know completely why
we or anything else sees color at all
clearly it's some kind of information
clearly it's evolutionary evolutionarily
useful
part of the answer might be here if
you're local to long now you might
recognize the salt ponds
at the southern edge of the san
francisco bay those colors
come at least in large part from salt
loving extremophile microbes
called halo bacteria halobacteria aren't
bacteria at all
they are members of the kingdom archaea
the oldest life on earth three or four
billion years old
obviously they do not see they don't
have eyes they are six microns long
they have color which means they have
pigments lots in fact
and they also know how to avoid blue
light and swim toward orange
which is weird because again no eyes so
halo bacteria
have a protein called bacteriorhodopsin
they're using it not to perceive light
but as a proton pump
basically they turn light into energy
but the thing is
that while the overall structure of the
protein is pretty close to ours
the individual amino acids that make up
that protein are different
it's like uh making the same spaceship
with different legos
so no one knows for sure if our color
vision
evolved from their color vision or if
color vision is so evolutionarily
valuable that that evolution just comes
up with it
again and again and over time the same
approach with different structures
nobody knows it's good for something and
we humans keep making our own colors to
feed our appetite for it
this is blombos cave it's on the coast
of south africa
it's been the location of a bunch of
really exciting archaeological finds
over the years
some of the first ornamental beads one
of the first drawings that human beings
ever made between 10 and 20 meters down
about 100 thousand years old the
archaeologists who worked that cave
found something
remarkable these are abalone shells and
the one on the right
you can see a little rock down at the
bottom and it's sort of molded to the
shape of the inner surface
than the nacreous substance on the
inside of the shell and you'll see also
some reddish color there that's ochre
and iron oxide these are tools for
grinding that ochre down
for mixing it with they found samples of
what's called trabecular bone like you'd
find in the spine it's sort of
fat and marrow and cartilage porous and
gooey these are tools to mix all that
together and make
a pigment to turn ochre into a paint
it's the oldest known example
of human beings taking a natural
material and turning into colored stuff
they can use
the archaeologists who found them led by
a researcher named christopher
henschelwood
called these tool kits blombos was a
workshop
for making color technology but by the
time you have people painting
for example the insides of the caves at
lisco in the south of france tens of
thousands of years after what was going
on blombos
you have a pretty wide palette now this
isn't obviously enough of a gamut
to depict the entire natural world but
there's a lot of color there you've got
the ochres there's some coppery stuff
for green
the blacks are magnesium and carbon like
soot that's easy because you've got
fires
and sometimes you'll have something
almost always calcium carbonate based
for white and it's enough to make some
really striking image like these these
are from
the simulated lisco cave that the french
built just outside the real cave but you
can also ask
could the people who painted it also
have had other pigments
and the answer is yes maybe they had a
blue made from flowers or something
we know because they were humans that
they saw color like we do
we don't know if they made colors like
we do i mentioned the color white a
second ago
people actually argue about whether
white is a color or not an achromatic
something without color one eminent
color scientist called it this though
the mother of all
hues to some extent the history of the
way human beings have interacted with
color has been
a steady or punctuated progress of
having more and more pigments
and more and more ways of making things
have colors
but throughout all that time one of the
most steadfast principles you have to
have
something to make white something to be
a substrate that you can put other
colors against
something that when you mix it can
either make those colored things
lighter or give them more opacity or
make them brighter
so that essentially has been having to
have a white pigment
it's white is one of the bases of the
axis that you can measure
um colors and brightness by it's been
omnipresent
in coloring roman buildings in the same
era that it was making ceramic and the
tang dynasty was also
became the basis for makeup that women
there would wear all the way up through
those famous pictures of queen elizabeth
with the sort of white cake
on her face that was all white people
really vibe on white stuff though
calcium carbonates include things like
lime and also kaolin which is the
mineral that makes ceramics and fine
porcelain possible
people try to make white pigments out of
all kinds of stuff in fact partially
that's because you need it to mix with
other pigments to
lighten them and brighten them and make
them more opaque but white's actually
tricky because
where most pigments as i said absorb
some wavelengths and reflect others
white has to reflect pretty much all of
them but not
back the way they came because that
would be a mirror basically why it is
organized disorganization
refracts every wavelength every which
way for something to be white the
particles inside it have to scatter all
wavelengths equally and efficiently
water droplets suspended in air are very
good at this that's clouds protein and
fat suspended in water is very good at
this that's
milk for most of human history though
the big white was this lead white
it was a component of makeup it was a
component of house paints it was a thing
that artists use
of course lead white was also scary
because it was hugely toxic and everyone
knew they knew since ancient rome how
toxic this stuff was
so much so because there was so much use
of it in the 19th century for industrial
uses and for paint because everybody
wanted their world to have nice colors
that the hazards of it had been become
the incentive to invent the entire field
of occupational safety
it was a mess which means the world was
open to a replacement
in the late 1800s an engineer named
august rossi
came from italy to new york and he made
kind of a business out of understanding
titaniferous ores
especially because people were trying to
mine iron out of the adirondacks and
make steel and that was like 25 percent
titanivorous
so at that point most people thought
that the way you would make good steel
out of something like that was to take
the titanium out
but in 1908 rossi noticed that the
chemical process he was using to purify
titanium produced as one of its
intermediate steps a fine brilliant
white powder
he mixed it with salad oil and famously
brushed it across a piece of paper this
was a big moment
rossi knew about the dangers of lead and
he understood the hegemony of national
lead conglomerate that was selling the
stuff in paint
so he and his partner added a new
business line titanium dioxide pigment
it's the basis for all kinds of paints
and coatings it has a huge refractive
index
it's opaque and it's bright you find it
even coatings and paints of other colors
it's the it's the main ingredient in a
lot of those paints
you also find it in coatings of pills
some kinds of paper almost every
cosmetic in your medicine cabinet
sometimes in the white sugar powder on
supermarket powdered donuts because it's
relatively inert
used to be an oreo filling it's a
multi-billion dollar industry
internationally
drives a huge amount of business the
bright colors of modern art of the
industrial age
of streamlined modern that's this this
stuff and it's it really
it's everywhere even today sprinkles and
sudafed and
toothpaste this was all part of what
one historian is called a chromatic
revolution
in order to make products seem new and
modern they
took on new colors and that started a
kind of um
inter-relationship a dynamic where new
technologies would create new colors and
those new colors would inspire people to
create new technologies back and forth
even though there's some kind of crass
capitalism involved there
the the transition
in a you know really weird but i think
real way of
of dorothy walking from kansas into oz
of a world that goes from being not
black and white or sepia tone because of
course that's just the way people
now will think about it because we're
influenced by the way the movies looked
but
but colors that were more likely to fade
and that were more likely to be earth
tones
into something vivid and vibrant that we
think of as the
as the 20th century and now the 21st it
was titanium dioxide
really that was one of the things that
made that possible what
didn't exactly change though and what's
still kind of unclear is how we talk
about those colors this is changing
direction a little bit but
i want to ask you another question do
you see the color blue in this painting
this is the painting athena appearing to
odysseus to reveal the island of ithaca
by giuseppe buttani it's a depiction of
a scene from homer's odyssey
those stories or rather one specific
read of those stories sparked a
tremendous controversy
that an increasingly colorful world only
made worse does everyone see the same
colors
if they don't have names for them or
read that differently what do you call
the colors between the ones you know the
names of
and what does that say about you and
your culture and about how the brain
works because
color is a really good way to understand
linguistics which makes it a really good
way to try to understand cognition
in 1858 uh 10 years before this guy
became prime minister of england
he wrote a book called studies on homer
in the homeric age he pointed out that
homer never used a word that meant blue
or green
in the original sure the sea might be
wine dark and dawn might be rosy
fingered but like
what does that even mean gladstone had a
hypothesis
the ancient greeks he said didn't see
color like we do they didn't say blue
because they couldn't see
blue that's nonsense of course they were
humans they had human eyeballs and
brains they
didn't lack the blue photoreceptor or
have different eyes that function
differently than ours
and you know maybe the ocean wasn't blue
maybe it was green or
black but most translators today agree
that the greeks were using color words
just differently those were colors that
meant something to them that had what
scientists call salience um you remember
those color orders that i showed you
plato's version of that went from white
to black and one of the primaries that
he used
was translated roughly to like sparkling
or brilliant that was a
specular illumination that specular look
was something that they valued
so that may be what the wine dark sea
was all about
um still though you know the idea that
some people you know other kinds of
people didn't see color as well as like
nominally civilized colonialists did
that was a pretty sticky
idea so grant allen thought that he
would test it out
alan was actually one of the inventors
of both science fiction and detective
fiction
but allen tried a cool experiment he
sent letters to as he said missionaries
government officials and other persons
working among the most uncivilized races
not above a bit of casual racism was our
grant
he sent those all over the world asking
those people to ask the locals
a bunch of questions and the answer at
the end basically was
yeah they all see the same colors they
don't all have the same names and
sometimes they don't have
some names for colors at all but if you
teach people the name in a different
language they pick that right up
people were seeing the same colors they
just didn't call them the same thing it
had
something more to do with culture than
with biology this was all anecdotal of
course what all this
eventually led up to in the 20th century
was a mutation idea into what's
now called linguistic relativism
sometimes this is called the superior
warf hypothesis
after a harvard linguist named edward
sapir and an autodidactic fire
investigator
self-taught linguist named benjamin
wharf and the the most simplistic
version of the idea
even defining this is controversial but
just work with me is that
the things that you have words for in
your head or a limit on what you can
actually think of and about
language is thought like i said color is
a very good tool for thinking about
language so you can test this or you can
try
in the 1960s two linguists brent berlin
and paul k had noticed in their field
work
that some languages had fewer basic
color words things like yellow and green
like i asked you to imagine up at the
top
that didn't mean anything other than a
color than other languages did some
languages had fewer than others
why they decided to do a more rigorous
version of what allen had tried to do
with his letters
what berlin and kay tried to do was ask
people basically which colors are which
what they're called which ones are
subcategories
what names do you have and so on and the
crazy thing is
they found a pattern they found that all
languages
develop color terms in a specific order
they said
first they start with white and black
then they'll include a red
then you get either a green or a yellow
then you get both then you get blue
and so on it turned out to be pretty
wrong
under fire for potentially some racial
assumptions and also because they
talk to people who are bilingual so the
languages would be overlapping and a
bunch of other things
they tried it again they went big they
went not to bilingual speakers in the
california bay area but to influence
around the world dozens of different
languages and places
and they found that what was going on
was much more complicated and mannered
that languages tended to separate their
color spaces into light colors and dark
colors and then develop more words as
needed
from there what we're talking about here
is something called categorical
perceptions the ability to distinguish
among stuff
and name that stuff so having words for
things really does matter
this is just a small example but russian
speakers have two basic color terms for
blue
they have a light blue and a dark blue i
won't try to pronounce those because my
russians
i don't have any russian um so whereas
we just have blue they have two
if you show people uh
those colors and then uh one of the
other ones so a triangle test two of one
color one of the others
um russian speakers are faster at
telling you whether the third one is the
same or different than the others
than english speakers are the hypothesis
there being the idea being that if you
have the words for it
then you can see it more quickly you can
think about it more quickly
what you'd really like though if you
wanted to try to separate cultural and
linguistic influences on color
perception from like innate biological
categorical perception of color
you would want something that could see
like a human but didn't have language
so i recommend one of these this one is
mine
from many many years ago so and you
can't have that specific one
but something like this and seriously no
for real this works you do what anna
franklin at the university of sussex did
you strap some four months olds
into car seats and make them look at
colors because babies
if they see something unfamiliar they
look at it for longer it's kind of a
basic tool in
developmental psychology and you can
tell what categories they distinguish
between and which ones they don't if
something they haven't seen before they
look at it longer if they've seen it
before it's already in a category then
they're looking for shorter
uh anna franklin tried this and found at
the end basically the babies see
red green blue yellow and purple
before language these are the categories
of color
but what are the categories for what do
they mean
in 2017 a couple of researchers ted
gibson who's an information theorist at
mit
and bevel conway who's a color vision
researcher at the nih and sort of my
guru in all of this
they tried the same kind of show the
colors came with speakers
that the berlin and k folks had tried
with native speakers of english
spanish and chimane which is an
indigenous language in south america
this shows which modal terms or basic
color words the speakers
of each language used for man cell chips
it shows that shimano had fewer words
fewer speakers had modal terms for those
colors than spanish or english did
but then they tried something new they
played a sort of guessing game they
would take the color chips
and try to see how long it took people
in each language to describe a given
[ __ ] to explain which one they meant
to a person they were talking to and the
idea was that if you had
fewer words to do this if it took less
time to do it that meant that the color
was somehow more information efficient
in the language that you were speaking
so these are from the top to bottom
different languages english at the top
then spanish speakers then gmail
speakers
and right to left information efficiency
it doesn't really matter which specific
colors do which
because you can see what the overall
divide is there you can see that there's
a division between
what someone who's an artist like conway
is would call warm colors
and cool colors so there's roughly the
same difficulty conveying the idea of
the same colors
but in both colors and the warm longer
wavelengths
are the ones that uh that are more
efficient
why are they more salient you can tell
as many evolutionary just cell stories
about that as you want but this is sort
of clear proof that at least they are
somehow
okay so what's next that's how we make
colors and think about colors now a
little bit
but because of that relationship between
technologies for making colors and
thinking about them
this is all changing a couple years ago
i went to a lab at mit
researchers named yang she and michael
foshee they work with a 3d printer to
try to
basically forge paintings not for
criminal reasons but
what they're trying to do is print
paintings
that look indistinguishable from the
originals no matter what color light
you look at them under now that's a big
deal the way the iron brain remapped the
colors that we're seeing to account for
the color of the surface the thing that
we're looking at but also the color of
the
ambient illumination is a vast mystery
nobody realized how the brain does it
and what they wanted to do was create a
printout essentially of a of an image
that would look the same under the same
kinds of different lights
as the original so to do it they kind of
reached back into the past they took a
process called half toning putting
little dots of color
next to each other to make color
printing that's how color printing works
familiar if you're a fan of comic books
or magazines or
neo-impressionism but instead of
limiting themselves to cyan magenta
yellow and black the classic colors of
magazine publishing
they added a bunch a bunch of pigments
red green blue violet orange
even a titanium white of course they
used a machine learning algorithm
and told it to look at colors that it
saw in the world and figure out how they
changed in our different illumination
and then come up with print the same
colors that the originals
they were able to pull it off almost
completely that's an original on top and
then the copies are below basically
every scanned pixel of the original
gets a a three-dimensional um like
hyperspectral reflectance map
that the computer then recreates with
pigments and the 3d printer multiple
layers of 3d printer
now there's some kind of color physics
going on there that figures out how
light interacts with surfaces
but nobody knows what that physics is
she and foshee don't know they left
the machine algorithm so they don't know
how it works either the computer is able
to make fake colors that nobody else
knows how to make
somehow and nobody has yet asked the
computer
one of the things that the color
scientists that i talked to were most
excited about
were the possibilities less of like high
resolution
screens and more of wider gamuts so the
color gamut is what colors are able to
be shown by a screen
and the idea isn't that you'd be able to
show colors that people
can't see but to capture more colors
that they do see out in the world
so right now if you have a screen with a
to narrow a gamut and you try to show a
sunset
let's say you won't it'll it'll it'll
like cover up the colors that it can't
depict so everything will just look like
the same yellow instead of a bunch of
yellows and golds let's say
so a color gamut a wider color gamut is
part of what
new and oncoming standards in
high definition tvs and digital
televisions will have
but they were actually more excited
about high dynamic range
dynamic range is a different axis in
color space it's the light to dark axis
not the not the colors the actual hues
and if you can increase that axis if you
can make the dark super dark and the
bright
super bright you can show more colors
you can expand the gamut
but also some people think that you can
even get more
like emotional range there's a
researcher at dolby who studies
neuroscience
as well as how to make better screens
and she says that
if you have really really super high
dynamic range and you like
look at fire for example that your your
skin will respond as if you're seeing
heat
um pixar animators use the
six primary color laser projectors of
dolby high definition
digital cinema and the ultra high
dynamic range ramp from
bright bright white to black black black
and they're doing experiments with
inducing after images
using really bright colors to induce the
after image that's the complement of a
color
so that you'll see colors that aren't
really there
uh more colors and colored things are
still coming
every time people learn new color
science they use it to make new color
technology like
these are all samples for possible
paints for cars
um and uh the way you do this is um
you include in the paint mica little
flakes like corn flakes
and they reflect light in different
directions and different amounts of
light in different ways so you get the
sort of
when you move around the car it's red
over here and green over there
um but mica actually um comes with a lot
of impurities
so they're they're trying to use
artificial
synthetic mica maybe vantablack
nanoscale nanostructure black that's the
blackest black ever known
or maybe what you see here this is a
work from the researchers jingu park
and ben rogers at harvard these are
structural colors they're not made from
traditional pigments at all
they're they're nanoscale structures
tuned beads of styrofoam
actually that reflect light
mechanistically rather than chemically
i don't know if you're if you're an
entomology fan but a lot of beetles have
really extraordinary
carapaces they're the armor that they
have someone that's really specular it
looks like metal
glowing um and there's one called the
cyphoculus i'm probably pronouncing that
wrong
that's ultra bright white uh brighter
even than titanium dioxide is and it
does that
um not because there's any white pigment
in it because the the way that
the nanoscale the way its armor is
structured and after that
i don't know because of course no color
is impossible
there's no missing shade of blue even if
the ones that we can see
are limited by our own biology and our
own neurology the colors that we can
make
are probably not thank you
thank you so much adam that was
fantastic and i'm really glad you're
able to join me here
at the interval in san francisco for
some live questions welcome thank you
i'm always happy to be at the interval
it's nice to be back
excellent well um this is a fantastic
talk and i love how kind of
first principle it is and it makes you
question everything you kind of know
about
you know the way you perceive the world
i mean your last book um
that you spoke here on was on history of
alcohol and culture
um this is a pretty big departure from
that so like how did how did you end up
down this path
i know everybody i i've had i have some
bosses who wish i would stick to a beat
man
[Laughter]
i i uh i think i've only written about
obsessions i have these two
these two twin obsessions and i got one
out of the way but even before i started
thinking about the booze book i was
thinking about colors and trying to
understand i mostly started
a couple different ways i actually went
back and realized that my
my eighth grade science project was
about how the eye sees colors and i did
a poll of my class um
just like show them colors and ask them
to name it try to do the berlin and k
thing with my with my classmates um they
also they all say the same right
uh but um but i i about
like 20 years ago i got kind of obsessed
with titanium dioxide and you probably
saw me
starting to get automotive and glow
about this like why would anybody care
about this one particular
molecule this this mineral but i i got
obsessed because it
it was because it's ubiquitous and it's
hidden so
if you look around if we look around the
room we're in right now almost every
surface the humans
colored has some of that in it it's in
the paper it's in the plastic it's in
the paint it's in these
encodings and uh and i was just really
struck by that like that there was
stuff you know that there's a thing
transformed by a human hand by technic
that makes the world look the way it
does and that's that's um
not immediately visible but so visible
all at once and i just
i started doing what orders call
collecting string i just started
collecting files and those files got
bigger and bigger and bigger until
finally i
sort of thought okay i think i can
finally tell this story and that story
became the story of color and technology
together that story became the story of
how human beings
see and make colors because it's almost
a structural problem
if i wanted to say titanium dioxide
makes this really interesting way
that all of the other questions that the
front half of the book has to answer
from that what does scene white mean
what does white mean what is
what is make what do all the words in
that sentence actually mean and those
all
become chapters right indeed and i mean
you mentioned how um
certain cultures have maybe one or two
more words for
a color that helps them distinguish them
you know there's the
i think largely apocryphal notion that
uh people who live in arctic cultures
have many more words for snow
um but do they have more words for white
i mean i you know you mentioned this
place that we're in
i remember picking out the white for the
interval here and you know obviously
yeah i think the one that we ended up is
called frank lloyd white
and so you know people who like make
paints clearly make up a bunch of names
you know eggshell or whatever it is
um for white but to is you know besides
the current marketing efforts of paint
was there or
was there you know cultures that had you
know that worked in that that were out
at the ocean that had many words for
blue or arctic cultures many words for
white or jungle cultures that had many
words for green
uh there are many many cultures will
have
cultures will have um basic color terms
that may extend past the ones that we
would
native english speakers um like i am
uh might have uh i think
for the whites i don't remember any that
have multiple basic color i'm using this
this term of art basic color term
basic color term is the the things that
berlin and k were really interested in
linguistic search linguists are
interested in because they're um
they're the words that don't mean
anything else so not turquoise because
turquoise is the color of turquoise
right so there's like a metaphor an
object metaphor problem there but but
blue you know and not not uh
modified like a light blue words that
only are the metaphor for the color
themselves and i don't remember a lot
that have a bunch of whites
um i mentioned in the in the talk
russian has a couple
for blue japanese has some really
interesting
ways to express greens um because it
doesn't have a
straight ahead or at least for a long
time until some some
more recent uh contact with western
cultures
that it didn't have a like a basic green
term
but it had some terms for the green of
like a younger green shoot on a plant
they repurposed the word for melon into
an adjective or they were using them and
again
these are blue and green are often the
space where this happens in a lot of
different cultures because the
um well i say because like people are
sure but a lot of neuroscientists and
cognitive scientists and color
scientists
think that it's because the the blue and
green
colors are there a lot of individual
variation
in the receptors how many receptors
people have and how they're distributed
in the back of the eye
there's some variation in the way
people's lenses will deal with chromatic
aberration and blue
lights as we get older we see blue a
little bit differently so there are a
lot of things that change
that tends to be the that tends to be
the weird color space where things get
strange well i mean i love how you you
know brought up some of the old cave
paintings i
i went to some of those sites and a
personal
passion of mine as well and what was
really um
interesting to me was trying to
determine if you know the colors that
we're seeing
30 000 years later um are are those the
colors that were used are we missing a
bunch of colors that
you know that faded um i know they're in
you know the caves certainly helped them
and then also going to the egyptian
sites where
where they were protected you know these
brilliant brilliant colors that have
survived you know four or five thousand
years
but it's always i i wonder if do you
know if if they found
chemical evidence of other colors that
we're not seeing in lasko or these other
kinds of sites
not that i not that i know of there are
um
there are the chemical analyses of the
of colors on
um on these kind of cables or rock walls
they do the
the chemistry on what those pigments are
and i i haven't
seen any work that's like oh we found
traces of an organic you know flower
titanium white yeah although
there is some good archaeology on the
inca having titanium white like 400
years before
um before rossi invented it which is the
whole other room what was the white that
the egyptians were using they used a lot
of white uh
they did um they're they're using
calcium carbonates and
and some leads but primarily calcium
carbonate based water so those are the
those are the accessible ones
in the mineral the mineral whites the
the problem with calcium carbonate
white tab problem i mean obviously they
worked great but they're
in comparison to a zinc white or
titanium white they um
they don't have as good coverage so you
need more of it um refractive index is
lower
than a titanium or a zinc or lead white
i mean lead weight was the big
was the big advance it does everything
right too it's just got that problem
with the nerve
it's just you know your children you
know yeah
um i'd love to hear a little bit more
about the human tetrachromats and you
know i think we've talked a little bit
about this and
you know are they you know are they the
super tasters of color do they get more
than than i do
um i mean maybe i'm one i don't even
know i don't know how to test for it but
the
uh you know are they and then i also
there's also the color blind humans and
they they kind of have other
types of you know high contrast
superpowers um what is the
where do these fit in why do they do do
we evolutionary understand why we have
these
people it's great that you use the
analogy of a super taster
because that really does try to get at
the um
the problem the question that we're
asking is a is about
trying to attach metaphoric meaning to
to these words right so
um the equivalency that one might draw
if
if a person had an extra photoreceptor a
fourth kind making it making that person
a tetrachromat
or putting them in some way like birds
you know have those four photoreceptors
or the mantis shrimp with the twelve
would they see more
colors like see colors out at the edges
or
they see are they distinguishing more
finely
among the colors that they that we
already see
so where you and i would see the same
blue
uh this our our hypothetical and nominal
tetrachromat would see two different
ones would say oh obviously those are
two different colors
um and so that you know those those
people do seem to exist our own ability
even as
as trichromats humans that we're like
weird among the primates even the
primates don't really do that and
the evolutionary just some story there
that
you would tell would be to say well if
you're um
if you're a predator hunting especially
during the day
like the big giant reptiles were like
you know the dinosaurs and stuff then
it's really good to have really high
high grade high definition color vision
and you see that even today and their
descendants in the birds right and like
raptors having really good vision that
way that's finely grained and good
colors
whereas you're descended as we are from
the little nocturnal furry things that
were screwing around between their legs
at night trying to stay out of their way
and maybe find some bugs you don't
actually need color vision because you
don't really have a lot of colors to see
at night
it's good to have night vision so you
see that in other
some of our fellow mammals but uh
but it's only a mutation in one of those
receptors
that kind of doubles up makes a new
receptor that has a slightly different
peak uh sensitivity that the spectrum
that it sees or slightly
moved over along that along the sliding
scale
what we call the visible spectrum that
then humans and
primates that we're descended from
recapitulate the trichromatic color
vision
there are researchers who um who are
working on using genetic techniques to
give primates that don't have all three
photoreceptors as we do uh a third one
to see if they then see colors the way
human beings do and there's some
there's some indication that they might
that work has been going on for a long
time
color blindness that human beings with
non-standard color vision were actually
one of the beginning touch points for
how scientists figured out how color
vision worked at all
the uh the chemist john dalton who
invented the idea of the adam dalton was
himself colorblind and he he
was from manchester which when he was
growing up
was becoming the center of textiles as
part of the industrial revolution
part of textile work was having a lot of
different dyes and pigments to make
these decks of different colors
so he he started collecting different
bits of thread and stuff and saying what
color he saw
when he looked at it and finally wrote
about that and had his eye donated his
eyes to the local museum to see if there
was if they could look through it and
see if
colors look different if you looked
through the back of dalton's eyes wow
you're still at this museum you can go
and check them out you can say like i'd
like to see dalton's eyes please
um you can't see your nerves
but it wasn't it was work like that
there was some theoretical idea that
um that you could take what what newton
had described with this range of colors
and even you know his basic color terms
his primaries are sort of arbitrary as
well he was trying to match to the
alchemical and platonic octave and so he
named all these colors certain things
but like
if i look at a rainbow or a spectrum i
don't actually see those as well as
newton said that he did but people were
trying to figure out well how does one
color get to another how do they mix
adam light how do
the colors of light mix into another
color performing metamers
how do pigments mix and sometimes they
make new colors sometimes they just get
darker
these are all sort of mysterious things
scientifically um
so thomas young
figured out that because he was
interested in oscillation wavelengths of
sound figured out that there was some
overlap with what newton had been
talking about
in 1801 i think gives this braver a
series of lectures over the course of a
few weeks saying like actually all you
really need
to see all of this range of colors is
you really just need three
receptors any column receptors but you
just need three elements
in the eye that you can combine in
different ways and you'll be able to see
if you have more of one
and less of the other two or more of two
and less of one then you'll be able to
see this whole range
of wavelengths that he had done
frequency calculations for that really
matched newton's
calculations pretty well um he died
pretty early
he was a a savant scientist and who
actually went on and helped translate
the rosetta stone in fact
but it was uh james clerk maxwell then
who comes in and gets really interested
in the same work
all these cooks have been training using
things like spinning tops and mixing
pieces of paper like origami fold so
that they could mix amounts of colors
and
see how they mix together and see what
color somebody would see and say like oh
well if you have 30
more blue this is what color people
perceive um
again all working with people who were
color blind who did have color vision it
was different than most human beings do
to try to figure out well what
what's the difference and does it help
prove our point here what maxwell
finally did this is a great experiment
he had a device that could shine
different colored light into people's
eyes
and tune in a little bit like like the
experiment that i was describing that
i've
you know tried when i said try to
imagine what your favorite yellow is
what the best yellow is
he could do that with different colors
and and use it to create a triangular
color space where he would put
um red green blue at the vertices of a
triangle and then
the way they mix together would be along
the sides and then the way all three
colors mixed together would be how you
color the inside of the
triangle and did this experiment where
he showed people a specific color
people who had some form colorblindness
he didn't know there were a bunch of
different forms of colorblindness at the
time you
show people a certain color and then he
would show them other colors and ask
them
what they saw what color they saw versus
what color it really was
and it eventually saw that you could you
could plot those and they would make a
line
you could draw a line through them to
one corner of the triangle he realized
like oh that's the receptor
that those people are missing or that's
not functioning and these people's eyes
that one receptor and
he realized not only did that show kind
of how colorblind this worked
but also that it proved that
trichromatic theory that
most people that almost all people had
those three receptors that could do the
work
through this very complicated neural
calculation turned out to be much more
complicated than anybody expected
this with just those three that you can
make all the other colors and that's
intuitive to us now because
people are watching this on a screen are
seeing a screen where all of the colors
the
vast range if you're looking at a uhd
screen vast gamut of color
almost all the colors of the human eye
can perceive um are really just being
produced by
three different colors of leds and then
sometimes a white one too
cool and we're going to bring in uh one
of the founders of lung now
uh kevin kelly shortly um that after
this question though
you showed you know a lot of history of
color wheels and kind of
that that you know that that this
science is littered by the bodies of
people who tried to create the ultimate
color wheel but what
how how far do color wheels go back what
is the oldest one that we know
well so um a lot of theorists you know
as backstars plato certainly tried to
come up with an order
putting a color in order the oldest one
there's a wonderful book called color
ordered
by researchers named ralph quaimi cooney
i may be pronouncing his name i
apologize
and the oldest one that he identified is
actually a circle
of um of vials of liquid that are
different that are either from clear
through yellow to dark brown and what
they are a different color
or urine they use doctors using this
color wheel to identify like well how
sick is this person that's really dark
brownie
that's right our friend is pretty sick
um
and uh the thing i like about that the
most is that you had to
um to make it work you have to have uh
these glass vials you know around
basically what we call a boiling flask
now in the lab like
the same kind of thing that's hanging up
here at the interval with a lot of the
people's personal bottles
and those are the same kind of vials
that enabled um
arab scientists in the abbasid period to
start to figure out how spectrum and how
spectrum rainbows work so before newton
um that they were able to use to watch
how light reflected through those before
they had prisms
to try to figure out that oh different
you know that light maybe refracts
differently depending on what wave like
we don't know the wavelength is but
there's different kinds of light that
refract differently and maybe that's how
rainbows work there was the it was that
kind of work that led up to what newton
was finally able to do in 1600s
oh very cool um all right well welcome
on uh kevin kelly who
was the founding editor uh wired as well
as one of the founders of long now
um and wired where you work welcome
kevin kelly
that's great to be here adam i love your
book
and your talk it's really great to have
something that we take for granted kind
of exploded and
revealed to be as amazing as it is once
we
examine it and you've done a great job
in explaining that
there's a couple of um questions from
um listeners one jim jenkins from
youtube says is there a simple way to
tell if
a human is a tetrachromatic
super you know i mean like is there a
test to tell well
whether you have this uh fourth kind of
cone how do they test it that's a really
good question
uh you know i wonder if they're
see the problem is there's so much
individual variation already so that if
you went and got like the whole range of
munsell blues and put them down in front
of you and me we'd probably there are
probably some
that i think i'm just diagrammatic but
probably like i wouldn't see a
difference than you would too so it's
hard to do that kind of test without
doing
sort of the straight ahead genotyping
there must be a test but i i feel done
about this not knowing this but
there must be a test that you like you
should be able to go and get
isn't one of the home genome test tests
actually called color you would think
maybe they would
but there must be some people who have
maybe
a more refined ability to discern
colors that we couldn't
an ordinary person might not notice the
difference between um
for sure and this is this is actually
one of the places where the color book
overlaps with the booze book
because one of the things that research
into people who are master somalia is so
people who are very good at
identifying wines where they're from and
how they taste and all these fine grain
variations
research into what somalians are able to
do often says
that they they don't actually um have a
better sense of taste or smell than
what i might have is an untrained sort
of just person who likes wine
but they have a lot more words to
describe the things that they are
smelling and tasting and they can use
those to apply
to what they're doing and then that
gives them a greater range of just a
greater descriptive range
which is great it's one of the reasons
why um when you go wine tasting it's
probably a good idea to not get the
tasting words first
before you taste something get the tasty
notes after because it's really easy to
incept people with those tasting notes
right you can say like you're going to
taste the blackberry in this and
suddenly it tastes like
okay so that's true somalia i i think
that's also true in
brilliant artists or in people who are
textile designers
or people who are doing mosaic work that
they may have a much they'll have a
greater sensitivity to their possible
range and have more words to describe
them and that gives them
more more access more access to being
able to see these are different colors
that i can describe
so it's it is possible that i might be
able to see like yeah i guess those two
blues are different but
that's just blue i don't have a kind of
a way to say that they're different or
they're so close that i don't even
notice that they're different until
someone comes around and says like
actually that one's a little bit more
gray and then i go oh
right of course it is i didn't i didn't
have access to it and that's why the
linguistics and cognitive research and
of color is so interesting because it
can kind of
at least begin to reveal and get it so i
want you to put your
wired hat on and think about the future
of
color say 50 years smell
what what do you think some of the new
things in color
technology might be uh it occurred to me
that one thing we're seeing
is a shift from just reflective colors
that have
with pigments to these colors that are
being generated from leds and they're
generated i'm sure there's a technical
term for this and i could imagine a
world in 50 years where
most flat surfaces are covered with some
kind of screen and we're
emitting colors and maybe there's a way
to make
colors that we haven't seen before that
way
what what are you finding out what
you're describing are the are a
difference first of all between a
reflective surface and an emissive
surface
right okay add it to some subtractive
surface or additive surface where colors
are getting beamed out
and and and that the the transition from
surfaces uh it really comes along with
electrification in a lot of respects
being having colored lights that that
exist independent of the light the
natural light or lights we get from
burning stuff has been one of the signal
transformations in the way people the
colors that people saw and the way
people think about colors
one of the things that's happening now
is there's some conversation
about adding a fourth primary to
color screens so there's some science
that says you know right now essentially
they're red green and blue and you can
do some variations there you can have
uh as as some of the
ultra wide gamut uh screens we'll do
have two reds two greens and two blues
and you can use that for 3d vision but
you
can
you know with six primaries but they're
still red green and blue but there's a
notion that you could have a fourth
a fourth led in the in the grew space in
in the blue green space and so instead
of having the triangle of the gamut of
vision that fits over
all the range of all possible colors
you'd expand out to some
quadrilateral shape that would then fit
out over much more
of the the color space of all possible
colors
you'd be able to see more colors on the
screens but even then what you're trying
to do is really just match what what you
see in the
in the world the colors are already out
there
it's just trying to get them to be
artificially produced and beamed at us
but then you can also imagine um
the like an e-ink technology is a is a
reflective technology it's not an
emissive one those don't actually emit a
lot of light they reflect like that's
one of the reasons that you know
some e-readers are black right so some
of the work that i mentioned in the talk
about trying to come up with structural
colors uh
using essentially polymers like
modifying polymers for their shapes and
having different cores and different
size outside to come up with a
structural color that acts like a
pigment
something that's aimed at coming up with
e-readers and and
using less power for a screen they're
not bright enough to do that yet
but um but that could change it again so
we could be going back to in some ways
electrically controlled and
electronically controlled but but not an
emissive surface or reflective surface
and that would change again what colors
we would perceive
one of the the clever things that wire
did in its
the first couple of issues was in
addition to the usual four color
printing
we added day glow colors
which my understanding of it are
pigments that
take the ultraviolet light and use some
of that energy to kind of boost up
the reflective nature of the color so
you
get a more intense color and
do you imagine things like that
happening
in the emissive color space where we
would be able to
maybe simulate colors that we don't even
have names for right now
well this was some of the um some of the
work that they were talking about and
this they aren't doing this yet but at
pixar when they were talking about for
example
using the um the high dynamic range
ultra wide gamut high definition digital
kind of projectors that are now becoming
more and more common in movie theaters
and
eventually probably you know in home
screens as well because that's sort of
how this technology progresses
um to be able to use the
hot the human eye and brain's tendency
to um
to see after images totally well
understood but to sort of manufacture a
color after looking at color and the
famous example for this is like the um
jeff john's flags right if i may have
just mangled the artist's name i
apologize like the one of those famous
paintings is the the american
the united states flag but done in the
contrasting colors the common
color so that when you stare then you
look away and you see the flag in your
head
so if you could do that with like these
super bright screens to have
one so this is what one of the pixar
color scientists was talking to me about
that you could have this have the
color have one color be emitted in a
super bright form
in one scene with the expectation that
when the scene transitions you'll see
the compliment
in the next scene so the color won't
actually exist on the screen it'll only
exist in our mind
actually there'd actually be a great uh
test to sort out the robots
from the human because the robots i
wouldn't work that way
you're not saying that oh you're not
human
so you spent a long time working on this
book
has um doing the research
did it change how you saw the world or
how you saw color
personally did it impact
you and change your mind from even when
you first started writing it
by a lot um i actually had
i had a little i had a little bit of um
dorm room like existential crisis for a
while where
after talking to enough researchers
especially um especially after research
on the on the dress
that whether you know whether people saw
it blue or white and you talk to enough
of those folks and
they'll you get to the end of these
interviews and you'll and you kind of go
yeah but it was blue though
and they sort of go look it's it's it's
charming
that you think there's any such thing as
an objective color but there really
isn't it's just surfaces in the way they
interact with
you know with the quantum nature of the
universe and after hearing that enough
times you start to walk around looking
around like
oh man none of it's real like it's all
just a surface
with photons bouncing off of it um which
i finally
like that'll keep you up at night i mean
i i was starting to like really sort of
get a little nervous about that like no
it's like you gotta just own the fact
that you're
that our think meat makes a world for us
and we live in it and that's okay
um it's not just i'm not i didn't i
didn't degrade into
horrible solipsism my um my partner
at home is a weaver we have a lot of
looms and a lot of fiber and a lot of
textile
um in our house and i have a
vastly greater appreciation for the for
that work
um especially because and there are a
lot of ways that um
uh that weaving in textiles prefigure a
lot of the kind of math
um that computer scientists do now but
one of them is that when you're
when you overlap fibers and this is i
only know this because i would come home
and say did you know and
she would look at me go yeah yeah that's
what i'm doing with the thing i know
that
um that that you're not actually mixing
the
you're not mixing the pigments you're
not mixing the colors they're sitting
next to each other and when colors sit
adjacent to each other
they have all kinds of weird effects in
your eye your brain they assume some of
the properties of the complement of the
color
and and and with weaving specifically
they begin to act very much like pixels
because you make smaller and smaller
dots as the depending on the overlap and
you can make patterns with those
with those pixels they don't use that
terminology but a lot of the um
the early design that um computer
scientists had to figure out to make
pixels work on screens like
anti-aliasing that early max used to do
to make
uh to make text look curved when they
didn't have the resolution to curve it
those are things that the weaver has
discovered a long time previous to that
that they had to do with the colors they
were working with
so now the the the the dynamic in my
house of like what sort of color work is
happening on a loom at any given time
versus what i know about it and what she
knows about it
um has uh it has it's changed our
hobbies for the
for the better well it actually makes a
little loop back to the jacquard loom
and the beginning of programming and
there's the pixel
so um thanks for that um a little
closing the loop
um great book thanks for the great talk
i appreciate it
thanks thank you kevin um
yeah we've had several questions um from
the
uh from the internet um but
uh one of the ones so those guys those
guys uh one of the ones
and it correlates to one of the other
ones that i had when we first recorded
the talk is
um you mentioned briefly about zinc
white but
it seems confusing that we don't like
where why didn't sink white take off why
was
how why was it titanium uh cost
properties of the pigment itself and
also what happens when you mix it and
try to put it on a wall
um a lot of the there's the the the
visual properties of these pigments and
then also their straight ahead material
properties
but you can still get you know you can
go to a paint store and get as it gets
zinc white um
they exist and you use them and in fact
um
vince van gogh often painted the same
painting with different pigments to see
how they would act
so you can read van gogh's letters
online it's a remarkable resource
actually and
and he uh there are some letters that
he's got to theo to his brother
um those letters are often him asking
for money and asking
to pay for paint and in one case he
complains about the lead white and the
zinc white that he's using that i think
it's the zinc takes too long to dry
he doesn't want to use it because it
takes too long to dry he likes the way
it looks but takes too long to dry so
you think these like
these very um prosaic is the wrong word
but these pikan
factors that make one pigment more
useful than less
useful i asked a um a woman who
was at the smithsonian who studies lead
white in the history of ledway
um why you wouldn't transition when you
know when titanium became widely
available in 1920s really like why would
you keep why would anybody keep using
white and she said that there
the lead has a more has properties on
the brush
that were more pleasing to artists it's
called being thixotropic which is one of
the
best words i learned where when you push
it with the brush it moves with the
brush
but then when you brush away it stays
where it is and that's really
um that's something that if you're a
painter you really want because it means
you have more control
and so these are the kind of things that
make one pigment have a life or have or
be used in a different way than another
and another titanium some people find
titanium white to be quite cold
right to be too too blue i guess or too
much on the cold side they want
something warmer so you would see you'd
go to a
and then sometimes when they're on walls
they'll they'll turn yellow or they'll
spawn off if they are prepared properly
issues like that interesting um you know
one of the reasons i'm trying to think
of you know why
you know you showed some of the archaea
that have in some way color perception
um and then you know humans have clearly
have color perception
but you know as we've you know talked
about with the world war ii bombers
they're kind of
they were some of those were better at
actually
doing their job if they saw less color
um
but you know do we do humans have all
this color perception for danger of ones
is it for hunting do we know where that
you know is it so you don't eat the red
berry or the red apple as it were
right i mean one of the um one of the
ways that color scientists amuse each
other
uh after a long after in the bar at a
conference uh
is to go through the different
evolutionary stories but what's it for
though why is it why is it there it has
to convey an evolutionary advantage it
has to convey a reproductive
advantage or a sort of sexual selective
advantage and in fact this was
you know the color of the morpho
butterflies it was the thing that darwin
and wallace argued about
was specifically they were talking about
why do these things have color it
doesn't convey an advantage in fact it
may
it may convert disadvantage there's some
research on um
on guppies in mountain streams
in south america and this is sort of
famous animal coloration research
where the the guppies will have
different color they're the same species
of guppy but as you move down
the stream when they're a shrimp that
will eat the guppy they have different
colors
that either are more appealing to a
guppy potential guppy mate
or less appealing or like less visible
to the shrimp that are trying to eat the
guppy
and there's this balance and so what you
really want for the guppy is to have
colors that show up in the wavelengths
that the guppies see
but not in the ones that the shrimp sees
right um
so some of the you know some of the good
theories are the colors we see colors
because it's
you know for sex like all kinds of other
stuff that we do that doesn't seem to
have any other purpose
um because it's you know that's
important um
but uh but yeah there's a possibility
that it's because we're trying to find
fruit
in the in the forest fructivore
hypothesis you want to see the red fruit
against the green trees it doesn't
really make
that much sense because there's a lot of
green fruit and like a lot of our
primate ancestors eat the green things
so how does that help you really want to
be able to see shape
there's a hypothesis that it's a way to
be able to
better perceive uh emotional state
there are certainly primates that when
they're
when they're at their peak of their
fertility then parts of their body will
change color
when we uh we unconsciously convey
emotional state by changing color of our
skin if we have
if we have a skin color that you can see
that not everybody does the range of
human skin color is actually not that
wide it sort of goes from
you know pink to brown with a little bit
of red shade in it but within that
there's
a lot of dark light variation um but
still you can imagine like being able to
see if someone was blushing would convey
could confer some evolutionary advantage
potentially
these horror stories are really they're
they're hard to tell and they're hard to
listen to because there's no real way to
go back
and unpack the the truth of them
um as you say it clearly has some value
it has an informational value
um
but people who see a different human
beings who see a different range of
colors
have other abilities as well this is
part of the long time
it's one of the arcs in the book is this
the long-term war between form and color
since at least the um since at least the
greeks a conversation about this
mostly false dichotomy between whether
form was more important the shape of
things
which you really see by light and dark
really that's what we really mean unless
you're feeling them
um or the color of things and and that
really um
came to a peak with sort of the art
criticism of the late 19th century where
there were people who were arguing
people who arguing that color was more
feminine and therefore
less somehow less like a nonsense you
know completely
culturally colored with a lowercase c
argument right
but until uh really until the
renaissance if you had a statue
it was probably painted you if you
wasn't painted
then you didn't that's your show you
didn't have enough money to get a proper
statue essentially
and it wasn't until like michelangelo
and leonardo da vinci both essentially
said actually
we don't want to see any color on this
stuff it's just the form that's the pure
that's the purest thing but that
conversation is a truth and beauty
argument it's not a it's not a
informational or
reproductive or evolutionary value it's
you you don't have beauty without truth
or truth without beauty the foreign
right and i mean we're getting close to
the end here um but uh
one of the things that's interesting to
me is you talked a little bit about the
pixar thing of how
you know they're actually in a way using
a i guess you'd call it like a
psycho-chromatic effect
to create a new color right and um but
you know
is the electrification of have we has it
been studied as
electrification of societies and um
emissive technologies like televisions
and computer screens and now cell phones
is that changing at all the way we see
color do we know is it is it is that
affecting us
there's a um there's a pretty good case
to be made and some people did study
this for example in the case of the
dress i go back to this because i
covered it because it was a big deal
because it really changed
a lot of color science too um that the
fact that that happened
meant that there were certain years of
research that followed trying to figure
out this was the internet name of the
dress
yes and there's there's a case to be
made there that one of the reasons that
one of the reasons that that image
created a rigidly bimodal color illusion
right one where you like once you saw it
one way you didn't switch whereas with
like illusions of form
the the is it a woman or a duck or a
rabbit or a duck or
is the cube forward or back those kind
of illusions they're bimodal but
but when humans look at them we tend to
we tend to switch back and forth right
and one of the weird things about the
dress meme was that once you
once your brain decided which color
you stuck with it you couldn't you sort
of couldn't see the other one after
you're looking for a while you can't
i've started to be able to
anyway that's another one of those
things where i got totally messed up
when i look at it now
but sorry i looped a lot way away here
but the point i was trying to make
was that there's a case that one of the
reasons that happened was not just the
nature of that color but that people
were seeing it on emissive screens
you know everybody saw it on their
phones or on their
you know on their screen at work nobody
saw the the reflective image the picture
there wasn't one it was a picture taken
with someone's phone
so clearly that had something to do with
it right does it would
have happened with the actual dress at a
party right
uh and and the answer that's almost
certainly no um
and part of the reason why is that if
you were seeing well
actually i might reverse myself on that
but if you were seeing that dress in
real life
then when the thing happened that
probably happened with that image which
is
the person walked through a shadow
they would then walk out of that shadow
and your brain would correct
your brain would do the calculation and
go oh no no that wasn't that it was this
is this
i'm looking at it now and i can see it
in different circumstances and i can
subtract the illuminance
the illuminance from the object i can do
all the work of color constancy that i
need to do
um but in fact some of the research on
the actual dress
um there's a researcher in england who
got who bought it
the thing and and put it in a gallery
room
and then illuminated it with led lights
with red green blue leds so that you can
adjust how much of each of those lights
you're shining on it but it still looks
like normal
still looks like normal light so it can
if you and i walk in the room it seems
like it's being lit by white light but
in fact it's actually sneakily not white
light it's some
adjustment of colors for the leds and
they were able to make people see that
dress any color they wanted
oh wow and in fact it works on art too
like even art that you recognize you can
make any art
do the cathedral ruin you know what is
cathedral arena can look like
you know all any time of day that's the
sort of thing where you start to go like
oh maybe there's not a
it becomes the province of the
philosophers whether that object has a
color
that surface has a color or whether it
that color is created in a dialogue with
our eyes and our brains and our
cultural experience right i've certainly
heard you know when people talk about
you know paintings
that were created before electrical play
that you know if you're looking at them
in anything other than sunlight or
light you kind of aren't seeing them the
way the artist intended
that's an interesting question one of
our other questions is you know when
humans
colonize other planets orbiting other
stars you know how will the local sun's
unique
uh light spectrum affect their
perception so you know it's kind of all
the time
so one of my favorite things yes trying
to figure out in fact there are
researchers who study exoplanets who
both use the color that reflects off of
those planets to try to understand their
atmospheres because different
atmospheres will show different colors
as we look at those exoplanets
even the little tiny specks of exoplanet
that we can see but also
yes trying to figure out okay well there
are these are planets that have a
different have an atmosphere with a
different composition than ours
so that changes what kind of light gets
through they have a sun that's different
than ours
um so it's emitting a different spectrum
than ours is let's say there are plants
what color are the leaves what what's
that version of chlorophyll what's that
version of the pigments that are doing
photosynthesis
are they absorbing all of the light they
can so they would look black to us and
in fact
if it was a human standing there versus
some whatever primate thing whatever
lemur-like thing that evolved on that
world would have eyes that evolved under
that sun
in that atmosphere and would see those
colors in a very different way they
would have a different range of visible
spectrum
in the same way that on earth a bee or a
fish or a snake has a different visible
spectrum than a human being does
and you have to take all that stuff into
account they take it into account on the
on
on the cameras on the rovers that are on
mars right now perseverance has cameras
on mars
that are designed to take into account
both what
what the image that they see would look
like to a human standing there
would look like if it was illuminated by
earth light what looked like what
it would look like if it's illuminated
by mars light and
this is sort of a metaphor because they
don't the researchers don't think about
it this way but they'll say this is what
it would be what it would look like to a
martian
right interesting yeah it reminds me of
that one day
that we had kind of ominously
last year in the bay area when the fires
were so bad that the sun basically
didn't come up and
everything was orange and the kind of
hilarious part of that was that when
people use their iphones to take
pictures the iphones
color corrected all the orange away so
the only way to take a picture of it was
with like earlier
you know you know non non-software
corrected things
xander if the iphone couldn't take a
picture of it obviously didn't happen
exactly just like all my meals yes
the uh all right well i want to wrap up
you know thank you so much for this but
the
um the last question i want to ask you
the last time you were here uh amir
seven years ago was uh with proof and
now with this
and yeah what is the next first
principle-based project that you're
going to teach us about
in my booking space for 2028 yeah okay
we're filling up i know it took me a
long time to write xander
that's not what i'm saying this is long
now this it was short yeah you know i
think i just wanted to
are you working on a new project yeah i
i have i have some notions
yeah right that's i know that's all
we're trying to ask jesus man um
yeah i have some notions uh the that
that there was a
virginia pulse rule what a really good
book called the fabric of civilization
um that sort of uh
was like i was hoping there might be a
textile weaving thing there and i think
she wrote it
so maybe that's not gonna happen now um
i've gotten really i've spent the last
year covering
for wired covering covid19 and the thing
that i've gotten really interested in
there is
is sort of how to understand how science
works and how science does it and what
science is supposed to do because so
much of what has happened
um with this tragedy this pandemic for
the last year has i think come down to
not being able to explain
what what we know how we know it how
scientists know it how science what
scientists don't know and then how to
how to say that to people who
who don't have the same scientific
background or knowledge
and the very basic philosophy of how
trials work and how science works and
how scientists
come to know things has gotten i've been
really compelled
i've written a few things about that and
i i think maybe there's something there
too
i you know i don't know i've been
staring at a screen every weekend for a
while i might um
just go look at some colors outside in
the garden for a while right
please too well thank you so much and i
can't wait to
uh have a drink with you here at the
interval after this is uh
after this q a is done it's been a very
long time thank you so much for joining
us
thank you for having me it is it's a
pleasure and i'm i'm i'm glad to be back
and i want to thank you our audience
with long now and our members and our
sponsors of this series and looking
forward to having you at our next stop
thank you so much
[Music]
you